dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaifer
today we are going to talk about video
stabilization
a typical application of this is when we
record family memories
and other cool events and sometimes the
footage gets
so shaky that we barely know what is
going on
in these cases video stabilization
techniques can come to the rescue
which means that in goes a shaky video
and out comes a smooth video well
that is easier said than done despite
many years of progress
there is a great selection of previous
methods that can do that
however they suffer from one of two
issues
issue number one is cropping this means
that we get usable results
but we have to pay a great price for it
which is
cropping away a great deal of the video
content
issue number two is when we get the
entirety of the video
no cropping however the price to be paid
for this
is that we get lots of issues that we
call visual artifacts
unfortunately today when we stabilize we
have to choose our poison
it's either cropping or artifacts
which one would you choose that is
difficult to decide
of course because none of these two
trade-offs are great
so our question today is can we do
better
well the law of papers says that of
course just
one or two more papers down the line and
this will be
way better so let's see this is what
this new method is capable of
hold on to your papers and notice that
this will indeed be a full size video
so we already know that probably there
will be
artifacts but wait a second
no artifacts whoa how can that be
what does this new method do that
previous techniques
didn't these magical results are a
combination
of several things one the new method can
estimate the motion
of these objects better two it removes
blurred images from the videos and three
collects data from neighboring video
frames more effectively
this leads to a greater understanding of
the video it is looking at
now of course not even this technique is
perfect
rapid camera motion may lead to warping
and if you look carefully you may find
some artifacts
usually around the sides of the screen
so far we have looked at previous
methods
and the new method it seems better
that's great but how do we measure which
one is better
do we just look an even harder question
would be
if the new method is indeed better okay
but by how much better is it let's try
to answer
all of these questions we can evaluate
these techniques against each other
in three different ways one we can look
at the footage
ourselves we have already done that and
we had to tightly
hold on to our papers it has done quite
well in this test
test number two is a quantitative test
in other words we can mathematically
define
how much distortion there is in an
output video
how smooth it is and more and compare
the output videos
based on these metrics in many cases
these previous techniques are quite
close to each other
and now let's unveil the new method
whoa it scored best or second best
on six out of eight tests this is truly
remarkable
especially given that some of these
competitors are from less than
a year ago that is nimble progress in
machine learning research
loving it and the third way to test
which technique is better
and by how much is by conducting a user
study
the authors have done that too in this
46 humans were called in
were shown the shaky input video the
result of a previous method
and the new method and were asked three
questions
which video preserves the most content
which has
fewer imperfections and which is more
stable
and the results were stunning despite
looking at many different competing
techniques
the participants found the new method to
be better
at the very least sixty percent of the
time on all three questions
in some cases even ninety percent of the
time
or higher praise the papers
now there is only one question left if
it is
so much better than previous techniques
how much longer does it take
to run with one exception these previous
methods take from half a second
to about seven and a half seconds per
frame and this new one asks
for nine and a half seconds per frame
and
in return it creates these absolutely
amazing results
so from this glorious day on fewer
or maybe no important memories will be
lost
due to camera shaking what a time to be
alive
perceptilabs is a visual api for
tensorflow
carefully designed to make machine
learning as intuitive
as possible this gives you a faster way
to build out models
with more transparency into how your
model is architected
how it performs and how to debug it look
it lets you toggle between the visual
modeler and the code editor
it even generates visualizations for all
the model variables
and gives you recommendations both
during modeling and training
and does all this automatically i only
wish
i had a tool like this when i was
working on my neural networks during my
phd years
visit perceptilabs.com papers to easily
install the free local version of their
system today
our thanks to perceptilabs for their
support and for helping us make better
videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and i'll see you
next time